do anything you pop you know my phone my
wallet it goes up
No
hello the Internet we are by a fool
there is what potential we have here now
try and do the happiest belly flop
you've ever done pull-on smiles the
whole way down always got a sidewalk
sidewalk yeah outside but this is not
natural
okay ready yeah Oh
so now Dan's gonna fall directly
backwards inception style is not the
water
try not to wind myself die or hit the
bottom of the pool or get electrocuted
Hey
oh yeah hi paper
yeah winded oh god there read that look
ah what happens have you breathe in it
for a little bit
let's go the pool it's my back red
nice hairy there oh geez yeah great
already
alright got a few uh few jumps what you
gonna do now gonna do a sexy sort of
whale shake thing come out the water
like a whale but sexy well if that's
possible it's going to be five four
three two five okay
well that look pretty much my favorite
one is the one have you just backdrop it
that's not my favorite my bike really
hurts
that's absolutely kills it's really
interesting how the water at certain
speeches it's like a shell of you yeah
just when you only realize that's cool
war just looks cool I can really just
have a high-speed camera Nepal just be
happy in the tire actually took quite a
lot of concentration to maintain those
faces and like poses into the water yeah
bite difficult what aren't you go bad to
film it you know so it's nothing to do
it being cold or yeah like [ __ ] would
you want to film it sorry into it we
feel really the right that's exactly
what it's like yeah follow us on Twitter
subscribe thanks for watching
Dan's and a half